Traductor: Larisa Esteche
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Las medidas de tiempo más antiguas
eran las observaciones de ciclos
del mundo natural,
usando patrones de cambios
del día a la noche,
y de temporada a temporada
para construir los calendarios.
Un registro del tiempo más preciso,
como el reloj solar
y al final los relojes mecánicos llegaron
para poner al tiempo
en cajas más convenientes.
Pero ¿qué es precisamente lo que medimos?
¿Es el tiempo algo que existe físicamente
o solo está en nuestra cabeza?
En principio la respuesta parece obvia.
—claro que el tiempo existe—
Se despliega constantemente
a nuestro alrededor,
y es difícil imaginar el universo sin él.
Pero nuestro entendimiento del tiempo
comenzó a complicarse gracias a Einstein.
Su teoría de la relatividad
nos dice que el tiempo
pasa para todos, pero no siempre pasa
al mismo ritmo para gente
en diferentes situaciones,
como aquellos que viajan cerca
de la velocidad de la luz
o que orbitan
un agujero negro supermasivo.
Einstein resolvió
la maleabilidad del tiempo
combinándolo con espacio
para definir espacio-tiempo,
que puede curvarse pero se comporta
de maneras consistentes y predecibles.
La teoría de Einstein parecía
confirmar que el tiempo
está tejido en la tela del universo.
Pero hay una gran pregunta
que no resolvió por completo:
¿por qué podemos movernos
por el espacio en cualquier dirección
pero en el tiempo en una sola dirección?
No importa lo que hagamos,
el pasado está siempre,
obstinadamente, detrás de nosotros.
Esto se llama el arco del tiempo.
Cuando una gota de colorante de comida
cae en un vaso de agua,
por instinto sabemos que el colorante
saldrá de la gota,
llenando finalmente el vaso.
Imaginen ver que sucede lo contrario.
Aquí reconoceríamos el tiempo
desplegándose hacia atrás.
Vivimos en un universo
donde el colorante de comida
se propaga en el agua,
no en un universo donde se junta.
En Física esto se describe
por la Segunda ley de la Termodinámica,
que dice que los sistemas ganarán desorden
o entropía con el tiempo.
Los sistemas en nuestro universo
pasan del orden al desorden,
y es esa propiedad del universo
la que define la dirección
del arco del tiempo.
Si el tiempo es una propiedad
tan fundamental,
debería estar en las ecuaciones
más fundamentales
describir el universo, ¿no?
Actualmente tenemos dos conjuntos
de ecuaciones que gobiernan la Física.
La relatividad general describe
el comportamiento de cosas muy grandes,
mientras la Física cuántica
explica las pequeñas.
Uno de los mayores objetivos
en la Física teórica
durante el último medio siglo
fue reconciliar
las dos en una "teoría del todo"
fundamental.
Ha habido muchos intentos
—ninguno probado aún—
y tratan el tiempo de diferentes maneras.
Curiosamente, un aspirante
llamado la ecuación Wheeler-DeWitt
no incluye el tiempo en absoluto.
Como todas las teorías del todo actuales,
esa ecuación es especulativa.
Pero como experimento mental,
si esa o una ecuación similar sin tiempo
resulta ser correcta, ¿significaría esto
que el tiempo no existe
en el nivel más fundamental?
¿Puede que el tiempo sea
un tipo de ilusión generada
por las limitaciones de la manera
que percibimos al universo?
Todavía no lo sabemos, pero tal vez
sea la manera equivocada de pensar en eso.
En vez de preguntar si el tiempo existe
como propiedad fundamental,
tal vez pueda existir como una emergente.
Las propiedades emergentes
son cosas que no existen
en piezas individuales de un sistema,
pero existen para el sistema como un todo.
Cada molécula de agua individual
no tiene una marea,
pero el océano completo sí.
Una película genera cambio
a través del tiempo usando
una serie de fotogramas
que parecen tener un cambio
fluido y continuo entre ellos.
Si miramos los fotogramas rápidamente,
nuestro cerebro percibe el paso del tiempo
de la secuencia de fotogramas.
Ningún cuadro individual
de la película cambia
o contiene el paso del tiempo,
pero es una propiedad que surge
de cómo las piezas están entrelazadas.
El movimiento es real,
pero también es una ilusión.
¿Puede la Física del tiempo
ser una ilusión similar?
Los físicos aún están explorando
estas y otras preguntas,
así que estamos lejos
de una explicación completa.
Al menos de momento.